It's peak pollination season, and my business is scaling fast. To keep the nectar flowing, I need a phone plan with top priority data speeds. That's why I chose Google Fi Wireless. My connections stay strong even when the hive is buzzing. Plus, unlimited plans started $35 a month. Now that's a deal that doesn't stay. Explore Google Fi Wireless plans today. Plus taxes and government fees.
现在是授粉高峰期，我的业务正在快速扩张。为了保持花蜜源源不断，我需要一个拥有最高优先级数据速度的手机套餐。这就是我选择 Google Fi Wireless 的原因。即使在蜂巢最繁忙的时候，我的连接依然稳固。此外，无限流量套餐每月仅需 35 美元起。这可是个难得的优惠。立即探索 Google Fi Wireless 套餐吧。另需缴纳税费和政府费用。
Google Fi Wireless is not subject to data traffic deprioritization during times of high network usage. think that the smartest way to make a decision is to gather all the facts, weigh them carefully, and then choose the most rational option. But psychological research suggests something different. Understanding the gist of a situation, not necessarily being able to recount precise facts, often leads to the best choices. Today we're going to talk to a psychologist who studies decision making about the importance of gist and why it can help explain everything from teenagers' propensity for risk-taking to the spread of health misinformation.
Google Fi Wireless 在网络高负载时段不会受到数据流量降速的影响。人们认为做决定的最明智方法是收集所有事实，仔细权衡，然后选择最理性的方案。但心理学研究表明情况并非如此。理解情况的要点，而不一定非要复述精确的事实，往往能带来最好的选择。今天，我们将与一位研究决策的心理学家探讨“要点”（gist）的重要性，以及它为何能解释从青少年冒险倾向到健康误导信息传播等各种现象。
So why does our brain lean on fuzzy thinking? And when is that a good thing? How do teens, adults, and artificial intelligence agents make sense of risk? And how can we design systems and messages that work with our natural decision-making styles rather than against them? Welcome to Speaking of Psychology, the flagship podcast of the American Psychological Association that examines the links between psychological science and everyday science. life. I'm Kim Mills. My guest today is Dr. Valerie Raina, the Lois and Melvin-Tuckman Professor of Human Development
那么，为什么我们的大脑倾向于模糊思维？什么时候这又是一件好事？青少年、成年人和人工智能代理是如何理解风险的？我们又该如何设计系统和信息，使其顺应而非违背我们自然的决策风格？欢迎收听《心理学谈话》（Speaking of Psychology），这是美国心理学会的旗舰播客，旨在探讨心理科学与日常生活之间的联系。我是主持人 Kim Mills。今天的嘉宾是康奈尔大学 Lois and Melvin-Tuckman 人类发展学教授 Valerie Raina 博士。
at Cornell University. She studies judgment, decision-making, and memory across the lifespan. She is the developer of Fuzzy Trace Theory, a decision-making model that has been widely applied in law, medicine, and public health. Her recent work has focused on understanding risky decision-making in adolescence, medical and legal decision making, and AI decision making. Dr. Raina is an APA fellow and has won many awards for her work, including the Lifetime Achievement Award from APA's Division of Experimental Psychology and Cognitive Science. Dr. Raina, thank you for joining me today. It's a pleasure to be here, and thank you for that lovely summary. Let's start with the core of your work. You develop something called Fuzzy Trace Theory, which I just mentioned. Can you tell us about that
她研究整个生命周期中的判断、决策和记忆。她是“模糊痕迹理论”（Fuzzy Trace Theory）的开发者，该决策模型已广泛应用于法律、医学和公共卫生领域。她最近的工作重点是理解青少年时期的风险决策、医疗和法律决策以及人工智能决策。Raina 博士是美国心理学会（APA）会士，曾因其工作获得多项奖项，包括 APA 实验心理学与认知科学分会的终身成就奖。Raina 博士，感谢您今天参加我们的节目。很高兴来到这里，也谢谢您那精彩的总结。让我们从您工作的核心开始。您开发了一种我刚才提到的“模糊痕迹理论”。您能为我们介绍一下它
and how it helps people make decisions? Well, as you mentioned, there's a distinction between mentally representing the gist of a situation, which is the meaningful bottom line of that situation, and what we call the verbatim representation. And by that, we mean a very literal and precise representation, as though you were memorizing experience and then trying to go on the basis of that to make decisions. And as you can readily imagine, if you're a very literal thinker, it's very hard to transfer your knowledge. So you learn about one particular patient if you're a doctor, but the new patient is like that patient. The gist is the same, but the verbatim superficial details might be different.
以及它是如何帮助人们做决定的吗？嗯，正如你提到的，在心理上表征情况的“要点”（即该情况有意义的底线）与我们所说的“逐字表征”（verbatim representation）之间存在区别。我们所说的逐字表征，是指一种非常字面和精确的表征，就像你在记忆经历，然后试图以此为基础来做决定一样。正如你可以想象的那样，如果你是一个非常死板的思考者，就很难迁移你的知识。比如，如果你是一名医生，你了解了某一位特定的病人，但新来的病人与那位病人相似。要点是一样的，但逐字的表面细节可能不同。
And life is like that. You gain experience as a child and as an adolescent, and you go out into the world, and now you're trying to transfer that information to new situations. And if you get the gist, if you get the bottom line meaning of the options before you, you're better able and better equipped to do that. And you also don't get mired in the minutia, the details that turn out not to be core to what really matters. Could you give us a few more real life examples of how people make better decisions when they focus on gist instead of getting bogged down and all these facts? Sure. And again, I want to underline. Facts are important. Knowing facts and having knowledge is extremely important in our perspective, but it's then extracting from those details what the
生活就是这样。你在童年和青春期积累经验，然后步入社会，现在你正试图将这些信息迁移到新的情境中。如果你抓住了要点，抓住了摆在你面前的选项的底线意义，你就更有能力、更有准备去做到这一点。而且你也不会陷入琐碎的细节中，那些细节往往并非事情的核心。您能再多举几个现实生活中的例子，说明人们在关注要点而不是陷入事实细节时，是如何做出更好决策的吗？当然。我再次强调，事实很重要。在我们看来，了解事实和拥有知识极其重要，但关键在于从这些细节中提取出
core meaning is for this situation. So it's not a fact-free kind of approach. It's a fact-rich kind of approach, but then you have to boil all that down to what does it mean? So a concrete example would be during COVID, a lot of epidemiologists were jumping up and down when the community prevalence rate of COVID infection was a very tiny 1% and then 5%. People were like, oh my goodness, that's huge. And I think most of us members of the public were thinking, gee, that seems like that tiny number. Why is everyone so excited? It is a tiny number. Literally, it's a small percentage. So if you just took the facts and you took them at face value, it would signal that there isn't much of a risk. But by the time the community spread of COVID is at 1%, it's huge. It's potentially catastrophic. And moreover, the increase is
针对当前情况的核心意义。所以，这并不是一种“无事实”的方法，而是一种“事实丰富”的方法，但你必须将所有这些归纳为：这到底意味着什么？一个具体的例子是，在新冠疫情期间，当社区新冠感染率仅为 1% 然后升至 5% 时，许多流行病学家非常激动。人们会说：“天哪，这太严重了。”而我想我们大多数公众会想：“哎呀，这看起来是个很小的数字。为什么大家这么兴奋？”从字面上看，这确实是一个很小的百分比。所以，如果你只是从表面上看待这些事实，它会暗示风险并不大。但当社区新冠传播率达到 1% 时，情况就已经非常严重了。它具有潜在的灾难性。而且，这种增长是
exponential, meaning that it goes up, up, up, up very fast. So that sense of up, up, up very fast, that's a gist. And the fact that a tiny number is a big problem. That's a gist. So if I want to buy a car or even a jar of peanut butter. Do I make a better decision if I'm working on GIST instead of trying to check out every available product that's out there? For example, if you look at nutrition labels, people are swamped by detail, and folks try to make it comprehensible. You know, it's a percentage of your recommended daily value. Well, what does that mean? And how do you compare this many grams of sugar to that many grams of, you know, this much carbohydrates to protein to, it is extremely hard for most people to grasp the gist. Is this a healthy food?
指数级的，意味着它增长得非常快。所以，“增长得非常快”这种感觉就是一种要点。而“一个很小的数字也是一个大问题”也是一种要点。那么，如果我想买车，甚至买一罐花生酱，我是不是在关注要点时比试图查看所有可用产品时能做出更好的决定？例如，如果你看营养标签，人们会被细节淹没，而人们试图让它变得可理解。你知道，这是你每日推荐摄入量的百分比。嗯，那意味着什么？你如何比较这么多克的糖和那么多克的碳水化合物、蛋白质？这对大多数人来说，极其难以掌握要点。这是健康的食物吗？
Is it not? Is it good to eat? Is it bad to eat? And nutritionists will then tell you there are no good or bad foods. It depends on how you're eating them. So now the person who's staring at those details on the label is completely perplexed. They're trying to get the gist of the information. So that's the key. To know whether it's the right thing to buy if you're interested in nutrition, if you're interested in taste, that matters too. You know, reward sensitivity and reward motivation is important in decision making, but also getting the gist of the facts. What are my options for this reward? I think the nutrition example is probably a real good one of being overwhelmed with the facts and not necessarily getting the point of the facts.
它不健康吗？吃它好吗？吃它坏吗？营养学家会告诉你，没有绝对的好食物或坏食物，这取决于你怎么吃。所以，盯着标签上那些细节的人会完全困惑。他们试图获取信息的要点。这就是关键。如果你对营养感兴趣，如果你对口味感兴趣（奖励敏感性和奖励动机在决策中也很重要），那么了解是否值得购买就很重要，但同样重要的是要抓住事实的要点。对于这种奖励，我的选择是什么？我认为营养学的例子是一个很好的例子，说明了人们如何被事实淹没，而不一定能抓住事实的重点。
Let's talk about young people in decision making because we know that. that teens are famous for making bad decisions. And a lot of people chalk that up to the idea that they feel invincible. But your research suggests that's not really the full story. So how does just-based reasoning help explain what's really happening when teens take otherwise unwise risks? That notion that adolescents feel invincible is interesting because it turns out to be false. It's a myth. They don't think they're invincible. They in fact estimate their own risks as higher for many of these behaviors than adults estimate their risk. So they know sometimes they're engaging in risky behavior. So then it's even more fascinating as to then why do they do it? The issue is that both adults and
让我们谈谈年轻人的决策，因为我们知道青少年以做出糟糕的决定而闻名。很多人将其归因于他们觉得自己不可战胜。但您的研究表明，这并非全部真相。那么，基于要点的推理如何帮助解释青少年在进行不明智的冒险时到底发生了什么？那种认为青少年觉得自己不可战胜的观点很有趣，因为事实证明它是错误的。这是一个神话。他们并不认为自己不可战胜。事实上，对于许多此类行为，他们对自己风险的估计比成年人估计的还要高。所以，他们有时知道自己在进行冒险行为。那么，他们为什么还要这样做就更令人着迷了。问题在于，无论是成年人还是
kids have what's called an optimism bias. They think they're a little less at risk than maybe the other person is. But they're weighing, in fact, what the research shows, and not only my own research but reviews of the literature and meta-analyses are consistent with this very counterintuitive prediction of fuzzy trace theory, which is that adolescents are often weighing the risks and reward, and they're combining them the way an economist would say you should to be rational. The problem is you have very small probabilities of extremely bad things, like HIV infection, or those kinds of things that can be life-altering. So if you're just counting, up, looking at the probability, the probability of transmission, even from an infected partner,
孩子，都有所谓的“乐观偏见”。他们认为自己比别人面临的风险要小一点。但研究表明，不仅是我的研究，文献综述和荟萃分析都与模糊痕迹理论这一非常反直觉的预测一致，即青少年往往在权衡风险和回报，并且他们结合这些因素的方式与经济学家所说的理性方式是一样的。问题在于，像艾滋病毒感染或那些可能改变人生的事情，发生的概率非常小。所以，如果你只是在计数，看着概率，即使是从受感染的伴侣那里传播的概率，
is actually numerically quite small. But that entirely misses the point, namely that you shouldn't do that because you might get infected. And the people who were infected, that's how they got infected. So it's not a question of it's just a small probability. And you have to calculate and say, well, I'm going to take an informed risk. That is an unhealthy choice. And the more that adolescents do that, which they seem to do, the more trouble they will get into and have bad outcomes, bad health outcomes and other kinds of public health outcomes. So if I heard you right, it's not that I'm an adolescent and I think I'm invincible, but it's, I'm an adolescent, but it's not going to happen to me. It's going to happen to her maybe, but not me. Is that the thinking? That's part of it. And by the way, that's true. Again, so many of these, this is why literal is not necessarily good thinking. Because literally that's true.
在数值上其实是非常小的。但这完全忽略了重点，即你不应该这样做，因为你可能会被感染。而那些被感染的人，就是这样被感染的。所以，这不仅仅是一个小概率的问题。你不能计算一下然后说：“好吧，我要承担一个知情的风险。”那是一个不健康的选择。青少年越是这样做（他们似乎确实在这样做），他们就越会陷入麻烦，并导致糟糕的结果，包括糟糕的健康结果和其他类型的公共卫生后果。所以，如果我没听错的话，并不是因为我是青少年，所以我认为自己不可战胜，而是因为“我是青少年，但这不会发生在我身上。也许会发生在别人身上，但不会是我。”是这种想法吗？这是其中的一部分。顺便说一句，这确实是真的。再次强调，这就是为什么“逐字”并不一定是好的思维方式。因为从字面上看，这是真的。
It's not that adolescence totally are, you know, in another reality. That's actually reality. The probability of these very catastrophic outcomes happening are often quite small. Now, they accumulate over time if you repeatedly engage in them. And that's one of the gist we used in an intervention we had for teens on premature sexual activity. We talked about cumulative risk ultimately being essentially certain. So if you have unprotected sex every month for a year, at some point during the year, virtually 100% of people, someone will become pregnant. So it becomes an all or none something, nothing gist.
青少年并不是完全生活在另一个现实中。那确实是现实。这些灾难性后果发生的概率往往确实很小。然而，如果你反复参与这些行为，它们会随时间累积。这就是我们在针对青少年过早性行为的干预措施中使用的一个要点。我们谈到累积风险最终基本上是确定的。所以，如果你一年中每个月都有无保护的性行为，在这一年中的某个时候，几乎 100% 的人都会有人怀孕。所以它变成了一种“全或无”的要点。
But each time is a small probability. So they are in fact unlikely to have these bad outcomes. That is in fact literally true, but that's not the way to look at it, we would say. The way to look at it is to put the whole picture together and to say, this is sort of like place. Russian roulette. In Russian roulette, you have only one bullet in the chamber, so you have a small probability. But the outcome is so bad, you shouldn't take that risk, even though you might think, well, for a million dollars, I'd play Russian roulette. It's rational, according to regular economic theories, to take that risk if the amount of dollars is high enough. But we would say the amount of
但每一次的概率都很小。所以，他们确实不太可能产生这些糟糕的结果。这在字面上确实是真的，但我们认为，这不是看待问题的方式。看待问题的方式是将整个图景放在一起，并说：“这有点像俄罗斯轮盘赌。”在俄罗斯轮盘赌中，弹巢里只有一颗子弹，所以概率很小。但结果太糟糕了，你不应该冒这个险，尽管你可能会想：“好吧，为了 100 万美元，我愿意玩俄罗斯轮盘赌。”根据常规经济理论，如果金额足够高，承担这种风险是理性的。但我们会说，金额和子弹数量是逐字细节，这仍然不是一个好主意。所以，这是您帮助开发的干预计划的一部分，即教导青少年进行不同的推理？正是如此。我们随后实施了该计划。我们采用了一个非常有效的项目，但其中包含一些我们认为在心理学重点上不足以触及年轻人的细节。该干预措施的雄心是：我们能让这些青少年像成年人一样思考吗？成年人看待这种情况的方式是：“你在开玩笑吗？”你知道，当然，没有人会玩俄罗斯轮盘赌。这毫无意义。如果你谈论的是美元，那有点……你知道，那有什么关系呢？
dollars and the number of bullets are verbatim details, and it's still not a good idea. So this is part of the intervention program than that you have helped to develop the teachers teens to reason differently? Exactly. We then implemented that. We took a really effective program, but that had some details in it that we thought were just not the right psychological focus to reach young people. And the ambition of the intervention was, can we get these adolescents to think more like adults? The way adults look at that situation is, are you kidding? you know, we, of course, no one would ever play Russian with that. That makes no sense. If you're talking about dollars, that's kind of a little, you know, what has that got to do with it,
或者子弹的数量。但如果年轻人以那种近乎超理性的方式思考，我们能让他们更多地从要点的角度思考吗？我们做到了。我们在治疗组和对照组之间实现了显著的差异。关于要点，更重要的是要点是持久的。当你在健康课上教年轻人一些东西时，你教给他们一堆事实。当他们后来在生活中试图应用这些信息时，留下来的是这些事实的要点，而不是逐字的细节。HPV 感染的百分比是多少？很少有人记得。但他们确实记得它比你想象的要高得多，对吧？这就像在疫苗接种前一样。它比你想象的要高得多。所以这种要点才是被保留下来的，
you know, or the number of bullets. But if young people think in that almost hyper-rational way, can we get them to think more in terms of gist? And we were able to do that. We were able to have a significant change between the treatment groups and the control group. And what's more about gist is gist endures. When you teach young people something in a health class, you teach them a bunch of facts. What remains later on when they're in life trying to apply the information is the gist of those facts, not the verbatim details. What was the percentage of HPV infection? Very few people remember that. But they do remember that it's a lot higher than you might think, right? This is like especially pre-vaccination. It was a lot higher than you think. So that kind of gist is what's retained
并且在长期内影响行为。这就是我们所展示的，它在长期内影响了行为。那么，转向基于要点的思维是人类发展中的一种自然演变吗？即当你从青春期过渡到成年期时，你就会“明白”了。这是否就成了你工作的方式？在许多领域的研究都表明，确实存在这种转变，从更字面的逐字思维转向更多的要点思维。这似乎取决于在某个领域的经验。
and what influences behavior over the longer term. And that's what we showed, that it influenced behavior over the longer term. And is moving to gist-based thinking a natural evolution in human development that as you move from adolescence to adulthood, that it sort of, you get it. It just becomes the way that you work? The research in many, many domains suggest that there is exactly that kind of shift, from more literal verbatim thinking to more gist thinking. It seems to depend on experience in a domain.
所以，如果你在一个领域刚开始是新手，比如医学生，你实际上可以作为成年人拥有这种经验，你会比经验丰富的心脏病专家更倾向于逐字思维。我们在我们做的一项研究中展示了这一点。因此，随着你在某个领域获得经验，无论你是孩子在生活中获得这些我们谈论的风险决策经验，还是你是医学生最终成为经验丰富的亚专科医生，你都在该领域获得经验。在这两种情况下，你都会表现出从更逐字、更字面的思维向更基于要点的底线思维的转变。让我们多谈谈医学和公共卫生。模糊痕迹
So you can actually have that experience as an adult if you start out as a novice in a domain, like a medical student, would be more verbatim than, you know, an experienced cardiologist. And we showed that in a study we did. So that as you gain experience in a domain, whether if you're a child, you're gaining experience in life with these kinds of risky decisions we're talking about, or if you're a medical student and then eventually you become an experience sub-specialist, you're gaining experience in that domain. In both those cases, you show a shift from more verbatim literal thinking to more just bottom-line thinking. Let's talk a little bit more about medicine and public health. How does fuzzy trace
理论和基于要点的思维如何帮助解释为什么误导信息如此容易传播？这是一个引人入胜的问题。这是我们这个时代最重要的问题之一。处理误导信息的初步方法是简单地给人们提供事实。这在青少年的健康领域是真实的，在这一领域也是如此。人们展示的是，仅提供事实似乎并不能改变人们太多。它似乎并不一定能纠正误导信息。它在一定程度上有效，但令人惊讶的是，它并不像应该的那样有效。原因之一是人们从事实中获取了什么。首先，存在动机方面的问题。他们信任
theory and gist-based thinking help explain why misinformation spread so easily? That's a fascinating question. One of the most important questions is, of our time. The approach of initial ways to deal with misinformation was to simply give people facts. And that was true in the health domain with teenagers, and that's true in this domain. And what people showed is that giving facts alone did not seem to change people that much. It didn't seem to necessarily redress the misinformation. It does to some degree, but it's surprisingly not as effective as it should be. And one of the reasons for that is what people are taking away from the facts. First of all, there are motivational things. Do they trust
提供事实的人吗？所有这些信息来源（无论是人工智能、社交媒体还是专家医生）的可信度都非常重要。但假设你信任与你交流的人，你是否抓住了信息的重点？你是否能够真正理解事实背后的“为什么”？这就是要点发挥作用的地方。所以，这不仅仅是事实是真是假，或者你是否有动力去相信它，或者它是否符合你的政治倾向等等。这些显然是事实，这些都是因素。但真正重要的是：这对你来说有意义吗？这符合事实的要点吗？当我们从外部视角审视这些事实时，我们说：“好吧，
the person giving them the facts? The trustworthiness of all of these sources of information, whether it's AI or social media or expert doctors, is really important. But given that you trust who's communicating to you, do you then get the point of the information? are you able to really understand the why behind the facts? And that's where the gist comes in. So it's not just whether a fact is true or false or whether you're motivated to believe it or not. It does it fit your political persuasion or whatever. Those are obviously those are true. Those are factors. But really what's what matters a lot is does this make sense to you? Does this fit the gist of the facts? And when we look at these facts from, you know, from an outside perspective, we say, well,
为什么那个人会相信那种事情？”嗯，从他们的背景知识和经验来看，那些误导信息是有意义的。它解释了一个非常复杂的世界，一个他们可能没有相关背景知识（如科学素养等）的世界。所以，在那个背景下，对于那个人来说，那个事实是有意义的。这就是为什么人们倾向于相信它。那么，科学家和公共卫生传播者如何利用您的想法更有效地向公众传达他们的信息？实际上已经有许多研究试图做到这一点，将我们的理论思想转化为人们非常实用的工具。2016 年有一项关于约 94 项研究的综述，其中一些是干预研究。
why does that person believe something like that? Well, from their background knowledge and their experience, that misinformation makes sense. It makes sense of a world that's very complicated, a world where they may not have the relevant background knowledge, like scientific literacy and so on. So that fact, in that context for that individual, makes sense. And that's why people tend to believe it. So how can scientists and public health communicators use your ideas to more effectively get their messages out to the public? There have actually been a number of studies attempting to do just that, to take our theoretical ideas and to implement them in very practical tools for people. There was a review in 2016 of about 94 studies, some of which were intervention studies.
所以你必须获取这些信息，并真正决定和提取它的要点。我们经常会与专家科学家、专家临床医生和专家患者组成的专家小组会面。我所说的“专家患者”，是指那些经历过这些治疗（如化疗、放疗和药物治疗）的人，他们知道经历这些治疗是什么感觉。仅举一个不同实施方案的例子，我们研究了类风湿性关节炎药物。这些药物被称为生物制剂，问题是，为什么在这些药物开发出来后，没有更多的人服用它们？因为它们对人们来说可能是一个非常好的治疗选择。它们既能减轻疼痛，又能改善他们的长期
So you have to take this information and really decide and extract what the gist of it is. So often we'll meet with a panel of expert scientists, maybe expert clinicians, and expert patients. And by expert patients, I mean, someone who's been through it, who knows what it's like to experience these kinds of therapies like chemotherapy and radiation and medication. So just to take one example out of the different implementations, we looked at rheumatoid arthritis drugs. These drugs are called biologics, and the question was, why aren't more people taking these drugs when they were developed? Because they would probably be a very good therapeutic option for people. They would both reduce their pain and increase their long-term
医疗结果。它会改善这些结果。所以我们通过与专家交谈，并试图从关于这些药物的所有技术细节中提取出底线意义（它们确实非常技术性），设计了一个干预措施。然后呈现这些信息。我们在一个非常简短的干预措施（一个在线工具）中做到了这一点。我们有真实的患者，我们观察了他们在该在线工具使用前后的选择。之后，他们的选择更加符合价值，
medical outcomes. It would improve those. So we designed an intervention by talking to experts and really trying to extract from all these technical details about these medications, and they are very technical. What's the bottom line meaning of this? and then present the information. And we did this in a very short intervention, an online tool. We had real patients, and we looked at their choices before and their choices after this online tool. And afterwards, their choices were much more value concordial,
这意味着他们有特定的价值观。他们不想有疼痛。他们想陪伴家人。他们有像那样非常核心、简单的价值观。获取干预措施的要点导致他们改变了关于药物的选择，使它们更好地与这些价值观保持一致并支持这些价值观。我们要休息一下。回来后，我将与 Raina 博士讨论虚假记忆，以及为什么基于要点的思维有时会导致人们记住从未真正发生过的事情。
which means they had certain values. They wanted to not have pain. They wanted to be there for their family. They had values like that that are very core, simple values. And getting the gist of the intervention caused to shift their choices and about medication so that they lined up and supported those values better. We're going to take a short break. When we return, I'll talk with Dr. Raina about false memories and how just thinking sometimes leads people to remember things that never really happened.
你的夏天从家得宝（The Home Depot）的阵亡将士纪念日促销开始。是时候用 Nextgrill 四炉头燃气烧烤架开启夏季烧烤了，特价仅需 199 美元。整个季节都可以用 Hampton Bay West Grove 七件套户外餐桌椅套装来招待客人，仅需 499 美元。这个阵亡将士纪念日，在家得宝享受低价保证。售完即止，价格有效期为 5 月 14 日至 5 月 27 日，仅限美国。适用排除条款。详情请见 HomeDepot.com/pricematch。你说这个地方离水边只有几步之遥。我们只是还没找到那几步路。
Your summer starts now with Memorial Day deals at the Home Depot. It's time to fire up summer cookouts with the next grill four-burner gas grill on special buy for only $199. And entertain all season with the Hampton Bay West Grove seven-piece outdoor dining set for only $499. This Memorial Day get low prices guaranteed at the Home Depot. While supplies, price invalid May 14th or May 27th, U.S. only exclusions apply. See Home Depot.com slash price match for details. You said this place was steps from the water. We just haven't found the steps yet.
我们省了多少钱？足够了。足够去迷失自我了。或者你可以预订希尔顿酒店的住宿。欢迎来到你的海滨客房。距离水边仅几步之遥。希尔顿促销活动现已开启。在 Hilton.com 或希尔顿应用程序上预订
How much did we save? Enough. Enough to get lost. Or you could book a stay with Hilton. Welcome to your oceanfront room. Just steps from the water. The Hilton sale is on now. Book on Hilton.com or the Hilton app
即可节省高达 20%，获得你期待的住宿体验。当你想要节省开支，而不是意外时。你住哪里很重要。希尔顿，为你而住。你研究过虚假记忆，对吧？那种人们认为自己记得从未真正发生过的事情的现象。当人们认为自己经历过从未经历过的事情时，他们的大脑里发生了什么？嗯，他们大脑中发生的典型情况是，他们记住的是所发生事情的要点，而不是实际发生的事情。
and save up to 20% to get the stay you expected. When you want savings, not surprises. It matters where you stay. Hilton for the stay. You've looked at false memories, right? that phenomenon where people think they remember something that never really happened. What is going on in people's brains when they think that they've experienced something that they never did? Well, the typical thing that's going on in their brain is that they're remembering the gist of what happened and not what happened.
所以人们主观地编码现实，但他们是并行地进行编码的。就好像在录制实际单词的同时，也在并行录制这个要点。所以他们有两种想法。因此，进入他们大脑的是这两样东西：逐字和要点。根据你提问的方式，你可能会得到逐字的结果，也可能会得到要点的结果。这与你提出的检索线索、问题的性质有关。我最喜欢的例子之一是医生，住院医生（实习医生）进去问病人：“你在服用布洛芬吗？”病人说没有。现在，他们最近去过急诊室，在那里被开了
So people subjectively encode reality, but they do so in parallel. It's as though there's a tape recording of the actual words in parallel with this gist that's being. recorded at the same time. So they're of two minds. So into their brain goes both of these things, the verbatim and the gist. And depending on how you ask a question, you might get the verbatim out, you might get the gist out. That has to do with the retrieval cue that you ask the nature of the question. So one of my favorite examples is with doctors where they would say, okay, the resident doctor, the doctor in training goes in and asks the patient. Are you taking ibuprofen? And the patient says no. Now, they had been in the emergency room recently in which they were prescribed
布洛芬。所以住院医生看着病历说：“你在服用布洛芬吗？”病人说没有。住院医生离开后，带着主治医生（高级医生）回来，说：“你在服用任何止痛药吗？”病人说：“是的。”然后医生说：“你在服用什么？你在服用布洛芬吗？”病人想了一会儿说：“哎呀，是的，我确实在服用。”所以病人对药物的逐字技术名称虚假地说了“不”，但当你问要点（“嘿，你在服用任何止痛药吗？”）时，答案是“是的”，结果证明就是那种药。当我指出这一点时，住院医生们非常高兴，因为他们经常因为这类事情被纠正。这与你如何向病人提问有关，
ibuprofen. So the resident is looking at the chart and saying, are you taking ibuprofen? The patient says no. The resident exits that comes back in with the attending, who's the senior physician, and says, are you taking anything for pain? And the patient says, yes. And then the doctor says, what are you taking? Are you taking ibuprofen? And the patient thinks for a minute and says, why, yes, I am. So the patient falsely says no to the verbatim technical name of the drug, but says when you say the gist, hey, are you taking anything for pain? The answer is yes, and it turns out to be that drug. The residents were very happy with me when I pointed this out because they get corrected a lot about things like that. And it has to do with how you ask the question
即问题中的检索线索。所以我们大多数人，在大多数时候，能更好地记住要点（“我长期在服用某种止痛药”）。这就是我们后来记住的，即我们确实有过这种经历。这就是医生所说的，你知道，他们说了那个，这就是他们记住的。所以你会虚假地记住经历过某事，因为你是在你对事件的理解下解释事件的。后来，你相信那就是现实。其中一个令人惊讶的含义（我们在数据中测试并发现它是真实的）是，你注意到我说过你这样做的倾向
of the patient, the retrieval cue in the question. So most of us, most of the time, remember better the gist, I'm taking something for paying over a long term. And that's what ends up getting, that's what we remember later is having, in fact, experience. That that's what the doctor said, you know, they said that, and that's what they remembered. So you will falsely remember experiencing something because you're interpreting events in a light of what you understand about them. And later on, you believe that that's reality. And one of the surprising implications of that, which we tested in data and found to be true is, you notice I said your tendency to do that
从童年到成年期会增加。你变得更加基于要点，这意味着你产生虚假记忆的概率会上升。所以你在逐字意义上并没有变得更准确。你变得不那么准确了。因此，即使在实验室环境中，如果你是成年人，你产生虚假记忆的倾向也比孩子高。
increases from childhood to adulthood. You become more just-based, which means your probability of having false memories goes up. So you don't become more accurate in a verbatim sense. You become less accurate. So your tendency to have false memories, even in a laboratory context, is higher if you're an adult than if you're a child.
我们展示了这被称为“发展逆转”（developmental reversals），因为它逆转了通常的预期，即成年人当然比孩子更自信，但实际上他们不那么准确，因为他们是基于要点的。你知道，我最喜欢、可能也是人们关于虚假记忆最显著的经历之一是，我在纽约市当记者时，正值自由女神像翻新期间。我和同事采访了许多人，他们坚持认为他们年轻时曾登上过自由女神像的火炬。当然，火炬已经关闭了几十年。所以这些人根本不可能登上
And we show that that's called development, developmental reversals because it reverses the usual expectation that, of course, the adults are more confident than children, but they're in fact less accurate because them are gist-based. You know, one of my favorite and probably more salient experiences of people with false memories came. I was a reporter in New York City around the time that the Statue of Liberty was being refurbished. And we interviewed, my colleagues and I interviewed a lot of people who insisted that they had gone up into the torch of the Statue of Liberty when they were youngsters. And of course, the torch had been closed for decades. So there was no way that these people ever went up into the
火炬，但他们坚持说他们上去过。他们甚至有登上火炬的心理图像，而我们知道他们根本没去过。我们可以在实验室中系统地创造这些经历。这就是为什么我们可以相当自信（就像科学中能做到的那样，这意味着总有警告）。但我们相当自信，因为我们可以在实验室中重现像那样生动的、现象学上具体的体验。所以，如果你反复检索你的逐字记忆，它就会加强并变得对你更生动。然后你开始润色它，为什么？因为它有意义。它是事件的叙述。它是事件的“为什么”。我当时一定在那里，因为……一旦你加上了这一点，它就变得如此可信和清晰，
torch, but they insisted that they had been up there. And they had like mental images of going up in the torch when we know that they could, it just didn't happen. And we can systematically create those experiences in the laboratory. That's why we can be fairly confident, as much as you can be in science, which means there's always a caveat. But we're fairly, because we can recreate a vivid, phenomenologically concrete experience like that in the lab. So if we have you retrieve your verbatim memory over and over, it strengthens and becomes more vivid to you. And then you begin to embellish it, why? Because it makes sense. It's a narrative of the event. It's the why of the event. I would have been there because. And once you add that, it becomes so believable and so sharp,
你的大脑会认为你经历过它。在你最近的工作中，你研究了人工智能代理是如何做决定的。你能告诉我们的听众关于那项研究的情况吗？你研究了哪些类型的决策？人工智能决策与人类做决定的方式相比如何？嗯，当我多年前刚开始时，我写过关于计算机如何做决定与人类如何做决定的比较。我谈到了人机不匹配。
your mind, you think you experienced it. In your recent work, you've looked at how AI agents make decisions. Can you tell our listeners about that research? What types of decisions have you looked at? How does AI decision-making compare with the way that humans make decisions? Well, when I started out and years ago, I wrote comparisons between how a computer makes a decision versus a human being. And I talked about human-computer mismatches.
因为当时的想法是计算机是更逐字的思考者，而人是更基于要点的思考者。所以当你把它们放在一起时，存在不兼容性。所以早在我们谈论计算机辅助决策时，这些计算机程序就会被开发出来，它们会输出（例如）针对病人症状的庞大诊断列表，而医生并没有轻易采用它们，但主要是抵制它们。部分原因是存在这种不匹配。这是一个基于证据的症状列表和非常公式化的东西。
because the idea in those days was that computers were more verbatim thinkers, but people were more gist-based thinkers. So when you put them together, there was an incompatibility. So way back when we talked about computer-assisted decision-making, and these computer programs would be developed, and they would output this, for example, enormous list of diagnoses given a patient's symptoms, and doctors did not adopt them readily. but mostly they resisted them. And part of that reason is because there's this mismatch. Here's a list of symptoms and this very formulaically based on evidence.
计算机试图辅助做决定。但它不是，它们做决定的方式与人类医生做决定的方式不同。也就是更基于要点。现在机器学习模型最终出现了，我也研究了那些，我现在也在研究。它们仍然在某种程度上是算法化和字面的。你知道，你可以谈论第二类错误和第一类错误，这就像：如果病人有病，计算机程序是否说有？或者当计算机说你有病但病人没有时，它是否会误报？它是否有漏报？病人实际上有病但计算机漏掉了。你可以谈论所有这些统计数据并将它们加起来，有各种各样的机器学习、汇总统计、精确度和召回率。但归根结底，这仍然是一种非常算法化、机械化、不太基于要点的决策方式。它可以总结关于病人的海量数据，但它不会像人类那样做决定。
Computer was trying to assist in making the decisions. But it wasn't, they weren't making the decisions the way human doctors were making decisions. So, which was more gist-based. Now machine learning models eventually came along, and I've studied those two, and I'm studying those now. Those are still somewhat algorithmic and literal. and you know, you can talk about, okay, type 2 error and type 1 error, which is like, okay, if the patient has the disease, does the computer program say it does? Or does it false alarm when the computer says you have the disease, but the patient doesn't? Does it have a miss? The patient actually has the disease and the computer misses it. You can talk about all those statistics and add them all up and there's all kinds of machine learning, summary statistics, precision, and recall. But at the end of, the day, that's still a very kind of algorithmic, mechanical, not very gist-based way of making decisions. It can summarize enormous quantities of data about patients, but it doesn't make the decision
所以我们一直在研究将机器学习模型与人类决策者（包括医生）进行比较，但最近我们有了这些大语言模型（LLM）的发展，比如 ChatGPT 和这类人工智能代理。确实发生了质的变化。我们大约在一年前发表了初步发现，例如在一篇论文中显示，当时的 ChatGPT（这是 3.5 版本）开始表现得像个青少年。它不像成年人类那样完全基于要点，也不完全是字面的。它表现出了一些过渡性的模式，就好像它是一个青少年。但它正在犯一些很有趣的错误。它表现出了认知偏见，
in the same way human being does. So we've been looking at comparing machine learning models to human decision makers, including physicians, but most recently we have the development of these LLMs, things like chat GPT and those kinds of artificial intelligence agents. And there has really been a qualitative change. And we published the initial findings of that, for example, in a paper about a year or so ago, showing that Chad GPT at the time, this was a 3.5 version, was starting, it was sort of like an adolescent. It wasn't, you know, completely just based, like adult humans, and it wasn't entirely literal. It showed some of the patterns that were transitional as though it were a teenager. But it was making some of these errors that are kind of interesting. It was showing cognitive biases,
认知偏见的萌芽，以及框架效应，还有人类（实际上是成年人）表现出的那种非理性行为。所以它是过渡性的。从那时起，ChatGPT 变得更加，我们认为，更加基于要点。它似乎正在经历这种发展模式。它曾经是个孩子，然后是个青少年，现在是个成年人，现在它可能会有虚假记忆和认知偏见。至少到目前为止，数据似乎是这样暗示的。你是否乐观地认为，我们能够纠正这些错误，即在人工智能背后掌管一切的人类，我们会变得更好而不是更糟？嗯，这很有趣，因为问题在于什么是真正的错误，对吧？这是一个问题。
the beginning of cognitive biases, and framing, and irrational behavior of the sort of people, adults in fact, show. So it was transitional. Since then, chat GPT has become even more, we think, more gist based than it's thinking. It's as though it's experiencing this developmental pattern. It once was a child and then it was an adolescent and now it's an adult and now it will probably have false memories and cognitive biases. At least that's what the data seem to suggest so far. Are you optimistic that we're going to be able to correct for these errors that the human beings who are sort of running the show behind the AI that we're going to get better and not get worse? Well, this is interesting because the question is what's really an error, right? That is a problem.
从严格字面的经济理性理论角度来看，这些人工智能代理和成熟的成年人类确实在犯错。没错。所以应该有一个你愿意为玩俄罗斯轮盘赌而承担的金额。或者你可以，你知道，它只需要是一个非常高的数字。或者你可以说，好吧，那是个例外，因为它涉及死亡。好吧，那么还有艾滋病毒感染。
It is certainly the case that from a strictly literal economic theory of rationality perspective, these AI agents and adult mature humans are making errors from that perspective. Right. So there should be amount of money you should be willing to risk on playing Russian roulette. Or you could, you know, it just has to be a very high number. Or you could say, well, that's an exception because it involves debt. Okay. Well, then there's HIV infection.
应该有一个奖励水平使它值得，对吧？那将是理性的选择，但不知何故，那似乎不是正确的选择。所以要点视角会说，这些认知偏见说明了关于人类的某些先进之处。所以我们现在试图研究的是：什么时候基于要点的决策实际上是正确的决策，尽管违反了字面准则或字面细节？我认为许多临床医生会对此产生共鸣，无论是心理临床医生还是医学临床医生。即有时病人不符合准则，而临床医生对此是正确的。
There ought to be a level of reward that makes that. worth it, right? That would be the rational choice, but somehow that doesn't seem like the right choice. So the GIST's perspective would say, these cognitive biases illustrate something advanced about people. So what we're trying to look at now is when does a just-based decision, actually the right decision, despite violating the literal guidelines or the literal details, and I think many clinicians would resonate with that, both psychology, clinicians, and medical clinicians. namely that sometimes the patient doesn't fit the guideline, and the clinician is right about that.
有时他们不符合，而临床医生是错的，因为他们可能没有跟上一切。但有时经验丰富的临床医生，准则是有例外的，而且是明智的例外。这就是要点实际上比字面机器学习模型或字面准则表现更好的地方。那么你接下来要做什么？
Sometimes they don't fit, and it's just the collision is wrong because they're maybe not having kept up with everything. But sometimes the experienced clinician, there are exceptions to guidelines, and they're intelligent exceptions. And that's where the gist would actually perform better than the literal machine learning model or the literal guidelines. So what's next for you?
你还在试图回答哪些大问题？嗯，你在人工智能方面已经触及了一些。我正试图真正掌握人工智能决策的本质。在短时间内发生了显著的变化。所以这是一个真正的移动目标。但这是我想理解的事情之一。我想推动关于人类的理论，但也推动关于人工智能的理论。所以从人类视角和人工智能视角来理解智能。我对这对现实世界决策（如公共卫生和医学）的影响很感兴趣。我最近做了一些关于认罪协商的工作，这类似于这些非常经典的决策场景，即你有一个确定的事情（即认罪），与一个赌博（即去审判）相对。去审判是一场赌博，因为总是有某种无罪释放的概率，但也有被定罪的概率。而且除了这些，还有不确定性。所以你在那里有一个经典的困境，在确定的事情和赌博之间，你有无罪释放的可能性。
What are the big questions you're still trying to answer? Well, you've hit on some of them in terms of the AI. I'm trying to really get my arms around the nature of AI decision making. There's been a remarkable change in a short period of time. So it's a real moving target. But that's one of the things I want to understand. I want to move the theory forward about humans, but also move the theory forward about AI artificial intelligence as well. So understand intelligence from a human perspective and from an artificial perspective. And I am interested in the implications of this for real-world decisions, things like public health and medicine. And I've recently done some work on plea bargaining, which resembles these very classic decision scenarios in which you have a sure thing, namely the plea, versus a gamble, which is going to trial. And going to trial is a gamble because there's some probability always of acquittal, but there's also a probability of being convicted. And there's uncertainty in addition to that. So you have a classic dilemma there between a sure thing and a gamble in which you have the possibility of acquittal.
所以我们最近将该理论扩展到了这一点，我们也将研究人工智能对此的方法。人工智能会帮助系统、法律系统吗？人工智能会帮助医疗系统产生更好的结果、更公平的结果、保留人道价值观的结果吗？即使不是人类在做决定。在这样的情况下，你将如何知道人工智能是否做出了所谓的“正确”决定？我的意思是，因为你要么去审判，要么不去，你知道，你不能两件事都做。
So we recently extended the theory to that, and we're going to be looking at artificial intelligence approaches to that as well. Will artificial intelligence help the system, the legal system? Will artificial intelligence help the medical system to produce better outcomes, fairer outcomes, outcomes that retain humane values? even if it's not humans making the decisions. In instances like that, how will you know whether AI made the, quote, correct decision? I mean, because either you go to trial or you don't, and you know, you can't do both things.
因此，我们最近将该理论扩展到了这一领域，并且我们也打算研究人工智能在其中的应用。人工智能会帮助法律体系吗？人工智能会帮助医疗体系产生更好的结果、更公平的结果，以及在即使不是人类做决策的情况下，依然能保留人文价值的结果吗？在那种情况下，你如何知道人工智能是否做出了所谓的“正确”决定？我的意思是，因为你要么进行审判，要么不进行，你知道，你不可能两件事都做。
Exactly. That is a real challenge. And we don't have good data about the outcomes of plea bargaining, too. They're not public records that are kept. You know, we've now made a lot of progress in medicine. And it's difficult because some of these same problems exist in studying medical outcomes. You know, that patient could have been sicker. That's why they had a worse outcome.
没错。这确实是一个真正的挑战。而且我们也没有关于认罪协商结果的良好数据。它们不是公开保存的记录。你知道，我们在医学领域已经取得了很大进展。但这很困难，因为在研究医疗结果时也存在一些同样的问题。你知道，那个病人可能病情更重。这就是为什么他们的预后更差。
That's often true, for example, of university hospitals. They'll get the most complicated patients. So if you just were to look at their medical outcomes, they might not be as good as a community hospital because that's all the hard patients were transferred from the community possible to the university hospital. So it's apples and oranges. So you're right, that's a very, if you only had real life data,
例如，大学医院通常就是这种情况。他们会接收最复杂的病人。所以如果你只看他们的医疗结果，它们可能不如社区医院，因为所有疑难杂症患者都从社区医院转诊到了大学医院。所以这是拿苹果和橘子做比较。所以你是对的，这是一个非常，如果你只有现实生活中的数据，
you have a real difficulty judging what a good decision is. Outcomes are good, but they're not enough. You need to have a theory of how did that, was that outcome reached? And can you really benchmark it against something where you kind of have a sense of what the right outcome is? So we're immersed right now in work and it's funded by some major agencies, NIST and SF, our funding work right now, where we have some idea with the doctors, you know, about patients that are exceptions, where we can put objective symptoms in and look at exceptions to guidelines. and really study those and try to approach this from a, is the just the right answer in some
你很难判断什么是好的决策。结果固然重要，但还不够。你需要有一个理论来解释那个结果是如何达成的？你真的能把它与某种你知道正确结果是什么的基准进行比较吗？所以我们现在正沉浸在一些由主要机构资助的工作中，NIST 和 NSF 正在资助我们的工作，我们对医生有一些了解，关于那些例外情况的病人，我们可以输入客观症状并查看指南的例外情况。并真正研究这些，试图从一个角度来探讨这个问题，即在某些情况下，正义是否就是正确的答案，
cases, as opposed to the verbatim details. With trial outcomes, it's harder because there's less of a database out there of outcomes just exactly as you said. I mean, that's where we were with medicine at one point. Now in emergency rooms, they collect data on outcomes of various kinds, for example, that they didn't use to collect. They didn't collect, you know, a lot of data in medicine. Clinical trials are a phenomenon, mainly of the 20th century. It wasn't forever that we had clinical guidelines in medicine. So I see that kind of future possible in law where we would collect data maybe anonymously, like we do in veterans hospitals about patient outcomes. We don't necessarily identify people because the point of
而不是逐字逐句的细节。对于审判结果，这更难，因为正如你所说，关于结果的数据库较少。我的意思是，这就是我们曾经在医学领域所处的位置。现在在急诊室，他们会收集各种结果的数据，例如，他们过去不收集这些数据。你知道，他们过去在医学中不收集很多数据。临床试验主要是一个 20 世纪的现象。我们并不是一直都有医学临床指南。所以我看到了法律领域未来可能出现的那种情况，我们可能会像在退伍军人医院收集病人结果那样，匿名收集数据。我们不一定需要识别个人，因为收集这些结果的目的是
collecting those outcomes is to better the system, to make the system more fair, to make the system better for everyone involved. So if we do that kind of thing, we'll have a better benchmark. But in the meantime, we're looking at various ways to look at hypothetical decisions and compare them to actual decisions. Well, Dr. Ran, this has been very interesting. I want to thank you for joining me today. It's been such a pleasure. Thank you so much. You can find previous episodes of Speaking of Psychology on our website at speakingofpsychology.org or on Apple, Spotify, YouTube, or wherever you get your podcasts. And if you like what you've heard, please subscribe and leave us a review. If you have comments or ideas for
为了改善系统，使系统更公平，使系统对所有相关人员更好。所以如果我们这样做，我们将有一个更好的基准。但在此期间，我们正在寻找各种方法来审视假设的决策并将它们与实际决策进行比较。好吧，Ran 博士，这非常有趣。我要感谢你今天加入我的节目。这真是太愉快了。非常感谢。你可以在我们的网站 speakingofpsychology.org 或 Apple、Spotify、YouTube 或任何你获取播客的地方找到《心理学谈话》之前的剧集。如果你喜欢你所听到的内容，请订阅并给我们留下评论。如果你有意见或想法，
future podcasts, you can email us at speaking of psychology at APA.org. Speaking of psychology is produced by Lee Weinerman. Thank you for listening. For the American Psychological Association, I'm Kim Mills. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
对于未来的播客，你可以发送电子邮件至 speakingofpsychology@apa.org。《心理学谈话》由 Lee Weinerman 制作。感谢您的收听。我是美国心理学会的 Kim Mills。本集目前还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子即可发表评论。